hello and welcome to the second
installment of intelligent squared
crypto a new debate series from
intelligence squared in partnership with
equinix
in the coming weeks we'll be bringing
you leading voices debating the
disruptive rise of cryptocurrency and
how it is shaping the future of money
and our responses to that i'm your host
and my cowboy from the economist and
tonight our debate contention is crypto
versus the environment
before we begin i'm going to ask you the
audience to submit your pre-vote to get
a sense of where your opinions lie
you can vote yes or no on the question
is crypto a threat to the environment by
the poll coming up on your screen if
you're unsure you vote undecided
take us a little while to calculate that
so please vote now yes no or undecided
and just while the many goblins in the
background do the counting uh warm us up
a bit for the debate and read you the
results of a twitter poll
that's been run in the aftermath of our
first debate which was bitcoin versus
gold
the twitter audience voted 82
bitcoin 9
gold and 9
undecided but you can catch up with the
debate and find out how the live
audience voted on the intelligence
squared podcast or on the youtube
channel i'm not going to give away too
much but it was a very different uh
outcome so have a look at those and see
which side you fall on we touched on the
environment in that debate but tonight
we're going to go into this argument in
greater depth it's estimated that the
global bitcoin network currently
consumes around 133 terawatt hours of
electricity every year that's roughly
equal to the consumption of sweden
crypto skeptics say that energy demands
of the network are a threat to the
environment and that further adopting
cryptocurrency will lead to a very
harmful rise in emissions however crypto
advocates say that the figures used to
denounce crypto are misleading and when
you examine the biggest contributory
factors to climate change globally well
bitcoin is responsible for a relatively
tiddly 0.13
of annual carbon emissions
unlike the traditional finance system
they would say networks like bitcoin
continue to make strides in adopting
renewable energy with initiatives like
the crypto climate accord committing
producers to net zero by 2040.
so who's right who's wrong well that's a
theme of our debate tonight and here's
how it's going to work in just a moment
we're going to hear our speaker's
opening statements they have six minutes
each to win you round to their side of
the argument i'll then moderate a
discussion between them so each speaker
can come back on the points made by
their opponent after that we will go to
audience questions please
save them up or even better put them in
the q a because that just enables us to
to sort them out as we go along and make
sure we get through as many questions as
possible indeed you can start submitting
them straight away on the q a button if
you'd like your name to read out do
include it before you hit the send
button
technology huh and feel free to say
where you're tuning in from this evening
that's always interesting for us to know
you can tweet along as well and the
hashtag is hashtag
iq2crepto
let's have a look and see yes we have
some results this is the moment of truth
and my
personal moment of eurovision
so
yes to the contention 40 percent hang on
the contention being which way around
let's get that right crypto versus the
environment
you mean yes for crypto can our goblins
just clarify
their cryptic uh messaging
something will shortly happen
yes it is a threat 40 percent
26 percent no it isn't a threat and 34
undecided we always like that because uh
gives us a lot to play for 40 yes 26
sorry no 34 percent undecided
well let's uh get to our speakers and
introduce them because they're going to
take this away our speaker arguing that
crypto is a threat to the environment
tonight is alex davis he's founder of
digi economist that's a platform
dedicated to exposing the unintended
consequences of digital trends he
started the bitcoin electricity
consumption index that's one of the
oldest most cited sources in the bitcoin
environmental and energy debate so alex
is going to speak for six minutes we'll
then turn to lynne alden i'll introduce
her more thoroughly when we've heard
from alex but alex the floor is yours
yes thank you
when i started running the bitcoin
energy consumption index back in 2017
bitcoin is joked that the network's
energy consumption only represented the
annual amount of electricity consumed by
christmas light in the u.s
now four years later this has this
amount has gone up more than 20 fold
putting the energy consumption of the
bitcoin network on par with the
electrical energy consumption of a
country like argentina and at the
current price the network could soon
consume as much energy as all data
centers around the world combined so
that includes all data centers we use
for traditional finance social media
cloud service the internet itself it
will represent
one percent of our total global
electricity consumption
all this energy is being spent on a
process known as mining in order to
create
new blocks of transactions for bitcoins
underlying blockchain bitcoin miners
have to participate in what is
effectively a massive gain of gas the
number only those who guessed correctly
are allowed to create the next block for
the blockchain and will be given a
reward for doing so
the whole bitcoin network currently
generates more than 140 quintillion
that's 140 with 18 zeros of such guesses
every second of the day non-stop
even so a new block will only be created
every 10 minutes on average if the
computational power in the network
increases the software just makes it
more difficult to guess the right number
which keeps the issuance rate steady
incorrect guesses which means almost all
of them serve no further purpose than
requiring potential attackers of the
network to make even more of those
useless computations than the ones
currently doing so if they want to do
harm to the network
as bitcoin miners get paid a fixed
amount of bitcoin for every block they
create their ultimate income strongly
depends on the bitcoin price that means
that as the bitcoin price goes up the
profitability of mining increases as
well and that also increases the
incentive to run more energy hungry
machines
we have seen the bitcoin price hitting
new all-time highs earlier this year and
that's why the energy consumption of the
network is now also higher than ever
before
this energy consumption has multiple
consequences and the most obvious one is
that generating the electricity that's
used by the network produces emissions
and the majority of this energy has
always originated from burning fossil
fuels
and because of this the emissions
associated with bitcoin mining are now
more than negating the entire amount of
net co2 savings from deploying electric
vehicles all around the world and if you
were to look at bitcoin and ethereum
combined ethereum being the second
largest cryptocurrency then the total
emissions would even amount to 100
million metric tons of co2 per year
that's twice the net co2 savings as a
result of deploying electric vehicles
it's also 0.3 of our total global co2
emissions as calculated by the
international energy agency and if the
current global chip shortage wasn't
holding back the growth of the network
we would be talking more in the range of
half a percent of our global emissions
at the current price levels
but as long as prices remain where they
are today we will probably get to that
point soon enough
bitcoin miners just love fossil fuels so
much that china recently completely
banned bitcoin mining as idle coal mines
were being revived for the purpose of
mining bitcoins and in this case that
also happened illegally directly leading
to a loss of human lives as these
operations lack proper safety
precautions in the us bitcoin miners
were responsible for reviving an old
natural gas plant in new york for the
purpose of mining bitcoins in montana
they closed the deal with a coal plant
that was scheduled to be closed and in
pennsylvania miners even started burning
waste coal which is a lot worse than
burning regular call in terms of
emissions
additionally a large chunk of the miners
that were sent away from china appear to
have found a new home in alberta canada
a third of the entire bitcoin network
may actually be moving there to take
advantage of leftover natural gas
capacity so that means that the network
isn't turning greener as opponents of
the digital currency argue
the need for both cheap and stable power
sources increasingly drives miners
towards obsolete and stranded fossil
fuel sources
now
the fact that these miners are all
looking for the same cheap sources also
drives them to the same location and
that adds yet another consequence to the
energy consumption as it can lead to a
local grid becoming overwhelmed you've
seen power outages in countries like
iran and abkhazia as a result of the
influx of bitcoin miners so people are
literally left in the dark because of
bitcoin mining and the consequences
don't even stop there
in particular bitcoin mining nowadays
requires highly specialized equipment to
be competitive that's typically
short-lived equipment that cannot be
repurposed at all so the electronic
waste that's ultimately produced by the
network as yet another layer on top of
the sustainability issues of the network
which is something that no amount of
renewable energy could ever address
now while tackling all these issues will
not solve climate change
up to half a percent of our global
emissions is obviously far from an
insignificant amount especially at a
time when every ton of co2 matters and
it also shouldn't be hard to see how
this can rapidly spiral further out of
control the hand the data centers
of the traditional financial sector
handle more than 700 billion electronic
payments a year bitcoin right now
handles about 0.02 percent of that
volume
while the energy cost already exceeds
the former so one can only really fear
what happens if bitcoin gets more
mainstream adoption because that will
surely drive up the bitcoin price and
its environmental impact
sounds like you're just about to come to
a ringing close there alex are you happy
on that closing point i was just about
to point out six minutes but you were
ahead of me this is a brilliantly
trained participant in these things your
body clerk if not your your digital [ __ ]
uh got you out in six minutes thank you
very much indeed and of course you'll
have time to complete some of those
thoughts and and reply to lynn who is
going to now take over the floor from me
lynn alden financial analyst founder of
lynn alden investment strategy she
provides tens of thousands of investors
with the latest research information and
tools to help them build wealth and
manage their digital assets one of the
world's best known bitcoin advocates her
workers featured in the wall street
journal business insider cnbc and much
more berlin tonight the intelligence
squared crowd is your audience six
minutes to convince them all right
thanks for having me um and so when we
talk about bitcoin the first thing is to
point out that you know it does have
benefits for the world and so it's you
know a lot of us kind of come at this
from kind of a privileged developed
market perspective but we look we take a
step back we look globally why was it
created what is it what is its purpose
and so the first thing is the fact that
you know roughly half the world's
population lives in some sort of
authoritarianism according to freedom
house um and also if you look at you
know the vast majority of emerging
markets well over a billion people most
of them have experienced either
hyperinflation or very very high levels
of double-digit inflation uh sometime in
their lifetimes uh and so there is a
very strong need for
basically you know some sort of currency
that is stateless that is permissionless
that can be sent without you know a
centralized third party being able to
block those transactions uh and to have
basically some degree of scarcity with
that currency uh and so that's that's
why we've had you know 12 years now of
rising popularity estimates show that
over 100
million people in the world have used
bitcoin uh and that number continues to
grow over time uh and so that that
naturally brings concerns about you know
it's is proof of work out there because
bitcoin uses proof of work the reason it
does that complicated process is because
that's what keeps it decentralized
basically work is what what verifies the
blockchain rather than any centralized
third party
and so bitcoin is not designed on the
base layer to be a rapid transaction
network although additional layers on
top of it like lightning liquid or
custodial transactions built on top of
that base layer can radically expand and
are rapidly expanding its transaction
throughput but the main purpose is that
decentralized savings and permissionless
payments technology now when we talk
about the scale uh you know bitcoin as
you know we've seen a number of excited
already but you know university of
cambridge estimates that bitcoin uses
about 0.1 percent or less of global
energy production
and so but the concern is what if that
scales up uh and in my view it will
scale up and that'll be a good thing but
when we you know it's important to
understand the details of how that
scaling algorithm works because every
time a new block is mined uh you know as
as the previous point out miners receive
a certain number of bitcoin but every
four years that number of bitcoin they
they earn goes down it's called the
declining block subsidy and so that's
why bitcoin miner revenue does not scale
as quickly as the market capitalization
and so for example back in 2012 when the
protocol is pretty new minor revenue
accounted for about 27 of bitcoin market
capitalization by 2015 that was down to
about nine percent uh by 2018 that was
down to about four percent and in the
first half of this year was down to one
point nine percent and over time you
know after about a decade that starts to
approach only transaction fees there's
you know virtually all the bitcoin are
mined and so miners rely on transaction
fees which so far have been a small
fraction of one percent of bitcoin
market capitalization every year
and so basically it becomes more and
more energy efficient every year as the
initial 21 million coins are distributed
and the system
shifts towards transactions and so it's
important to understand that long-term
scaling
rather than just you know the simplistic
method of taking market capitalization
and extrapolating it linearly
exponentially which i see a lot of
journalists and economic
people doing
and so you know lastly a key thing to
focus on is how bitcoin uses energy so
bitcoin is a buyer of last resort
because it has two very specific
qualities one is that uh it can go into
remote locations because it does not
require high bandwidth or high personnel
and that's so it's unlike a data center
it's unlike some sort of manufacturing
facility it can go out to remote
locations it can even co-locate inside
of nuclear plants
geothermal plants hydroelectric dams
solar farms uh stranded natural gas it
can go out to these locations
and the second you know feature of it is
they can it can withstand periods of
being turned off because it's not like a
data center uh any one bitcoin miner can
fluctuate as long as it it takes that
into account in terms of its contract
pricing and what we see generally is
that bitcoin miners especially as the
markets become more mature more
efficient
has shifted more and more towards these
agreements to take up excess
uh supply and so the way our grid works
and again this is something a lot of
journalists and economists miss is that
we have to produce more energy than we
consume
otherwise you know turning on the
marginal laptop would cause brownouts
right so we have to have more more
production than we have consumption
because we need that buffer but a lot of
renewable sources are are available
we're always on like solar wind
geothermal hydro nuclear and these
naturally have these periods where
they're producing more than the the grid
in hundreds of miles can take at that
current time and so what we're starting
to see more and more is that bitcoin
miners are co-locating and being able to
basically absorb that excess supply so
we calculate how much bitcoin uh uh you
know energy bitcoin uses that's largely
non-rival energy that's you know buyer
of last resort energy
to go into places where it's stranded
and even
an example earlier was stranded natural
gas and so according to cambridge uh you
know the world's stranded natural gas
could power the current bitcoin network
almost eight times over
and what that means is these remote
sites where they're getting hydrocarbons
and they produce a little bit of gas on
the side but it's not economical enough
to build a pipeline or take it and so
they literally burn it into the
atmosphere so bitcoin miners go out and
say okay you're going to burn it anyway
so sell to us very very low cost and we
will we will mine bitcoin with it and so
i think you're going to increasingly see
those sorts of things and i'm actually
excited for that because that can really
incentivize renewable energy and so at
the current extrapolation even if
bitcoin is 10 times bigger than it is
now because the declining block subsidy
its energy usage will not be 10 times
larger and then even when it was even if
it does get to that point it's actually
a very you know important aspect to the
grid this is a new type of energy buyer
which i think is going to actually
unlock a lot of renewable energy that's
available in the world
also a perfect six minutes you should do
gymnastic routines you too because
you're
right on time and and in the space let's
just dig into your arguments a bit while
we get in a few more questions the q a
is looking quite lively uh don't forget
to
send us your questions on the q a button
preferably on the q a button but i'll
get to them where i can find them but q
a's right in front of me let's talk a
bit about your opposing
arguments i suppose starting with you
alex i wondered how much you felt that
your argument was predicated really on
energy sources energy markets and the
climate change argument being
as it is now
and how much of it you might be prepared
to concede to
lynn if you were able to make great
strides forward as we hope will be able
to happen in in the near future on the
greatest sustainability of energy
supplies and bringing being able to uh
to trade off cost and efficiency better
than we have done would that change your
mind a bit
um well you know from for me uh let's
let's first of all
talk a little bit about maybe proof of
stake because
before talking about should we be using
more renewables for this or not you know
you can actually ask the question should
we even be running proof of work at all
or should we try to replace this
algorithm with something that doesn't
need
any any energy in the first place and i
think for me that is the natural
starting point
can we do bitcoin on a proof of stake
it's also mentioned in the questions as
actually ethereum is working on had a
second largest cryptocurrency they're
planning to migrate from their current
proof of work algorithm to a proof of
stake and if they succeed they just
cancel out 99.95 of their energy need
because
there is no incentive to run energy
hungry machines in there so you can you
get rid of the energy consumption plus
you get rid of electronic waste you get
rid of the impact on the global
semiconductor supply chain because of
machine demand
the whole
the whole package
um so if you can do that
yeah uh that that would be the perfect
outcome huh then you still have bitcoin
as it is today except you know the back
end is just a lot cleaner
um
now there is an if to that huh
we don't know if ethereum will succeed
that's one and b
uh if they would succeed whether that
would be uh implemented in bitcoin uh it
could theoretically happen but it
doesn't have to
uh
there might be a reason for bitcoin is
to start considering it if ethereum
succeeds but for now this is still a bit
of an uncertain terrain so then you get
to the question okay so what can we do
right now to try and make this a bit
more sustainable should we be working on
trying to get more renewables in the
network and then the unfortunate thing
is that there really isn't any mechanism
to force
miners to use more renewables miners
will go
where they can get cheap and stable
energy sources and particularly the
combination of those two because if you
happen to own a bitcoin miner you want
to run it as much as possible all the
time these machines are typically
becoming outdated pretty fast every one
and a half years or so you get a new
generation of machines so within that
time frame you need to earn your money
back you need to maximize your profits
so you want to have your machines
running all the time if possible that's
the way to maximize those profits and in
order to do that you need a stable power
source and unfortunately
there have been many talks of bitcoin
miners potentially using renewable
energy sources like solar archives did
an entire calculation of how that could
be done
but they had to state in that
calculation that for in order for that
to work
uh those mines would have to be shut
down during half the day because simply
yes there is an access during part of
the day but you know during the night
you have alex you've got quite a lot
there for lynn to reply to so if you
just want to wrap up your point but then
we can just get more of a conversation
going between you all right i'll keep it
short from here now what the thing i'm
trying to say is that
even if you try to move this network to
renewables renewable sources just aren't
the ideal power source that's why we see
these net these miners currently moving
to actually obsolete
uh or
hard to use stranded as lynn said
natural or gas or other types of fossil
fuel sources because that can provide
the combination of cheap and stable
power okay that's it well done thank you
thank you
lynn over to you might want to take that
last thought first just as it's fresh in
our minds that there was not a
sufficient enough incentive um for
bitcoin miners to to use sustainable
power and there were in a way the whole
market was sort of so distorted that it
was unlikely that my naive idea that you
could maybe just simply sort it by
saying well you push people in a more
sustainable direction
might not work we also had the question
about ethereum and anything else you'd
like to pick up
yeah so according to the bitcoin mining
council uh their data source uh the
bitcoin uh network is already using a
much higher level of renewables than any
country's uh specific grid any large
countries specific grid especially the
united states and so it's already
tilting in that direction
two you know for example quebec has more
spare hydroelectric capacity to power
the entire bitcoin network and there's
actually a pretty large concentration of
bitcoin miners there and more want to go
there but due to bureaucracy and
basically delays uh they're not allowed
to right and so that's basically they
rather have chosen to waste that energy
rather than have bitcoin miners come in
use that energy and so really kind of
comes down to bitcoin miners are happy
to go to these locations and it comes
down to which sources are conducive to
accepting them and again stranded
natural gas is actually one of the
cleanest energy sources because it's
literally otherwise burned and sent into
the atmosphere anyway and so you might
as well use it uh before it's wasted and
so actually that that ends up being
cleaner than if you were to build a
solar array specifically to mine bitcoin
because that does take energy to do
as for the proof proof-of-stake uh you
know comparison proof-of-stake is useful
for a number of protocols out there but
it does make a large number of
trade-offs compared to proof-of-work uh
specifically it ends up being more like
a corporate structure where it's
centralized around if you own more coins
you get more votes in the direction of
that network the monetary policy and any
sort of changes and so for example
ethereum is 70 pre-mined right so so 70
of supply was given to the initial
investors and creators um and then they
they're going to switch to proof of
stake where people that hold the most of
the coins will have a large
say in how that goes proof of work
however is you know the combination of
bitcoins distributed node network
distributed mining capacity
all these different kind of checks and
balance in the system make it purposely
resistant to changes it takes you know
very high level of consensus even among
individual users with small amounts that
are running their own full node in order
for that change to be able to go through
in addition you know even even the
ethereum developers themselves uh talk
about the fact that you know proof of
stake is far more complicated it's like
you know that the code base is like a
thousand times longer there's far more
attack vectors uh the basically the the
theoretical robustness is not as strong
and so it can it can serve a number of
roles for tokens that that act more like
equities uh but it's less ideal for like
a global distributed money like that
seemed to answer question i was just
going to press you on
your view of ethereum really because
that's something that's actually stalked
uh both of our debates that came up last
week yeah
versus gold as well it did just you you
had a kind of
contingent tone when you just discussed
it and you might also i'm sure a lot of
people on this call are great experts
but you might just try to nail the
difference for us if you could so
ethereum is is far more complex on the
base layer because its main main purpose
is to do smart contracts uh and so they
started with proof of work they're
planning on shifting to proofs of stake
and overall i because they you know
because they did a initial coin offering
uh because they have these kind of
centralized hubs of development and kind
of long-term road maps marketing budgets
i view them overall far more like
equities uh same thing with with the
theorem's uh competing protocols cardano
solana uh i view these like kind of more
centralized utility uh proof of stake
type of directions to be more like
equity so people can choose to use that
ecosystem if they want to use those
smart contracts whereas bitcoin is
serving a very different purpose of
essentially being an energy currency and
especially one that is uh you know it
doesn't really need incentives to go out
and use these stranded energy sources or
spare capacities and for example i i
mean you know i have electrical
engineering background i've talked to a
number of miners
they're increasingly co-locating inside
of of hydroelectric dams nuclear dam uh
nuclear facilities uh basically as the
as the market class has gotten more
mature got more visibility these these
uh large companies are starting to take
it more seriously and so we're seeing
more and more kind of shift they're
happy to go into these places and start
using these these wherever there's
sources spare capacity whether it's
renewable in many cases or some cases
stranded gas that again even though it's
a fossil fuel it's it's basically would
otherwise be burned and they come in and
buy it
so just before we get into our q a i
wonder just perhaps one or two thoughts
we'll keep it quite tight from each of
you
alex what may be the arguments that
you've heard from lin that you take most
seriously though that perhaps test
your own case
well you know the the difficult thing is
that when we're talking about proof of
stake there is indeed more trade-offs to
be made than just environmental ones hey
it's not just like okay we go from one
algorithm to the other and the only
thing that really changes is the
environmental impact that would be ideal
but that's not how reality work it's a
very complex
uh security uh situation and you know in
in the thing that i always that that
really bothers me is that bitcoin is in
general pretend as if
uh proof of work is the ultimate way to
do this type of distributed consensus
algorithms
because if you look at what's actually
going on in the bitcoin network we've
seen that over the past years especially
a majority of this bitcoin network just
ended up in china back in 2019 seven
75 percent of the bitcoin network the
entire network all the machines were
physically located
in china and such a consequence
concentration is actually a huge
security risk because it doesn't matter
whether you're on proof of stake or
whether you're on proof of work if an
attacker manages to get a majority it
puts the network at risk so in bitcoin's
case if the if an attacker manages to
get a majority of the machines in the
network it puts the network at risk and
having 75 percent
under the potential
control of a single government because
that government the chinese government
can just confiscate that equipment and
start using that to paralyze the network
that is a big risk and then on top of
that 80 percent of all that hardware was
being produced by a single manufacturer
being bit main who already backdoored
their hardware several years ago that
problem was known as uh and lead
i'm not sure i've yet yet heard a side
of lin's argument that you found more
convincing
well you know
what i'm trying to say is that you know
you can
say that
a change to proof of stake is not so
easy or hey it might not even be the
right solution
um but what i'm trying to explain is
that you know even from you know if you
look at other dimensions other than the
environment there's also still issues
with proof of work so it's it's it's
very complex yes
but
it's not just that proof of stake it can
be only superior in one way being the
environment it may be more waste than
one that i think answers a question sent
to us by festus so um or at least it
answers from alex's point of view
probably not from from linz lin what i
picked up from that please feel free to
come back on any of that briefly and
we'll go to the q a but what we haven't
sort of touched on perhaps
you've touched on but we haven't had a
question about it is uh it does give of
course extraordinary power to the
chinese government which has all sorts
of uh other side effects not least at
the moment in terms of global standoff
in geopolitics and trade is that
something worrisome
uh well the interesting thing is so the
one of the reasons there was so much
concentration of the miners in china is
because they had so much spare energy
capacity if you looked at the university
of cambridge again they tracked the
provinces where those miners were and
whenever there was the wet season about
half a year they a lot of them would
flock to uh you know that area of china
where they have all those over produced
hydroelectric dams and again that's
that's if they don't use that energy
it's going to be curtailed anyway
and so those miners come in they get
those really cheap energy sources and
then they would move out during the dry
season
and so basically that that you know
bitcoin kind of just goes to wherever
these stranded energy sources is and for
a long time that happened to be china
but as they increasingly connected their
grid and then as the chinese government
kind of
you know crack down on that uh you know
bitcoin miners fled out and kind of
sought out these other places whether
it's natural gas whether it's
hydroelectric in quebec whether it's
co-locating with nuclear solar
facilities we've seen that distribution
that's why it's funny because a lot of
say bitcoin bears were like oh china ban
bitcoin mining whereas bitcoiners like
this is great we're seeing a a
decentralization of the of the
geopolitics of bitcoin miners so i like
many other uh people that are say
bullish on the space i consider that an
overall positive we also just saw block
stream announced a large fundraising
round uh where they're going to uh you
know seek to build their own asics uh so
that should further decentralize not
only the the where the miners are
located uh but the the source of
manufacturing and the creation of those
miners and so i do think overall it is
healthy to see that system become more
uh decentralized over time and i guess
the last thing i would i would touch on
is that you know we're still you know
debating we're still kind of taking it
as granted that using energy is a bad
thing whereas it really comes down to
the type of energy you use in the long
run and so actually i would consider it
a like a literally a downside to you
know potentially how fast renewable
energy could grow if we didn't have a
proof of work buyer like bitcoin because
again
the ability to basically be have a buyer
of last resort to come in and buy spare
capacity that can lower cost for both
the producer and the other consumers uh
because you know that that spare energy
that gets wasted uh now gets monetized
and that that makes it so the producer
can charge less to other consumers uh
and so that can accelerate solar energy
production it can you know again soak up
all this uh you know the natural gas
waste we see a lot of kind of novel use
cases uh that bitcoin's allowed to bring
online because of its very unique
capabilities the data centers and other
things just aren't able to do
right let's crack into some questions uh
maynard clark says we could wonder about
the ecological arms of a great many
innovations including ethically
motivated ones plant-based meats cactus
leather fake leather etc fair point alex
uh which question was that
we could wonder about the well i i i
don't if you're seeing what i'm seeing
but the question i have is from maynard
we could wonder about the ecological
harms of many innovations so therefore
why specifically about crypto
well i don't think we're specifically
worried about crypto and if you look
around in the world you see that there's
many people worried about
all kinds of things it's uh
the
the thing is that we are dealing with
the climate crisis we need to reduce our
emissions we need to
be better at using the energy we have
and i would say that affects every
single industry out there and every
single industry will have their own
people uh worried about what's going on
there so
uh
it's not like we should be focusing on
just bitcoin or just something else i
think it's important that we spread our
attention and tackle all of those things
but of course yes bitcoin is playing a
role in that it's growing rapidly so
bitcoin should obviously be part of that
as well
frank thank you very much um over to you
lynn or something i quit
i just wanted to throw something that
was
named you forgive me i know everybody
suddenly become very active in my q a hi
everyone if you all just had a quick gin
and tonic or something it was along the
lines of as the developing world uses
more
crypto um does that not mean that you
know there's a bit of a tension there
with the desire for more sustainable
energy supplies that there would be a
reliance on fossil fuels if that was
spiking faster than developing countries
were adopting more sustainable energy
sorry can you repeat that question it's
basically if a crypto is being adopted
very fast in developing countries will
that not increase reliance on fossil
fuels
well again the adoption uh is not the
same thing as where the miners are
located uh and so you know as was
pointed out previously was the case a
lot of the mining was in china but
adoption was global and we see that now
i mean a lot of the the mining hazard
has shifted towards north america and
other countries um but for example we do
see a ton of adoption among users
in places like you know nigeria in
places like argentina venezuela and so
turkey it is common to see a lot of
those emerging markets especially ones
that have either suffered from high
inflation or authoritarianism uh
basically you know protesters having
their bank accounts froze and things
like that to adopt bitcoin and so it is
important to separate
the users from the miners because those
can be two very different things i would
like to see also see more mining happen
in developing countries because it could
benefit them economically it can help
them bring on some of their renewable
energy uh you know
capabilities because a lot of them do
have you know very rich resources for
hydro or geothermal or or deserts for
solar for example and you know the
bitcoin can potentially help them bring
that online
and we start to see more and more that
you know for example block stream now
has a uh you know a unit uh with bitcoin
miners in it and it's for basically you
know if someone sets up a solar facility
they can ship them that box and
basically again that box can absorb
any excess capacity that the solar
provides that maybe in opportune times
when there's not demand for it to help
that installation be more profitable and
so i'm really bullish on that kind of
long term
and there's a question i'm just going to
ask you to add a word on this and then
we'll flip both over to alex about how
bitcoin compares to the traditional
financial system in terms of emissions
are you able to give us any estimate or
scale of that it's a very good question
in terms of establishing a baseline here
so arc had an estimate i don't have in
front of me but they you know their
estimate was something like that the
traditional financial system is like 27
times you know more energy than bitcoin
uh gold is more energy than bitcoin uh
and that's of course when you take in
account you know
you know millions of people working in
in finance uh all the real estate
associated with it all that kind of
infrastructure built around it and
basically software can automate not all
of it but but a very significant chunk
of it so if bitcoin were to ever go up
say 10x or 20x from here um and even if
it's if it's energy usage starts you
know getting anywhere close to one
percent of global energy usage uh that
would basically eat probably a lot of
the you know the the
basically inefficient legacy system that
we see now and and add a lot more
productivity alex is anything on there
you want to come back on
yeah well i did see an estimate recently
that put
the total data center energy used for
the traditional financial sector uh at
somewhere around 240 kilowatt hours
which i thought was funny because the
total data centers in the world not also
including the financial sector is coming
down to around 200 terawatt hours so
that's including the data centers for
the financial sector so you would expect
that the total energy consumption of the
financial sector is less than 200 even
if it's the entire amount then bitcoin
is already getting pretty close to that
and the thing is that the traditional
financial sector produces or gen sorry
handles a lot more uh volumes yeah we
are talking about a volume of more than
700 billion payments
a year electronic payments i'm not even
talking about cash uh whereas bitcoin
it's purely digital and handles maybe
around 100 million transactions a year
so in proportion to each other bitcoin
is doing maybe 0.02 of what the
financial sector is doing and probably
already using more energy for that than
the regular financial sector so
uh
it seems quite quite off
one thing i would counter to that is you
have to include the millions of people
working in finance and their large real
estate that has nothing to do with their
data centers second of all when we look
at say bitcoin you can't compare
something like visa you have to compare
it to something like fedwire so fedwire
is a settlement network all these other
things like visa or these other payment
structures are on top of those
settlement networks like fedwire europe
has their own system you know all these
different places have their own kind of
it's a layered system and so we see with
bitcoin is that it's a lot like fedwire
where it's this it's this
relatively low volume about 100 million
a year 150 million a year but those
transactions can be arbitrarily large
and so what we're seeing now is that
with the development of the lightning
network which is fairly recent it
actually just kind of took off this year
it's been in development for about three
years
that basically can make an arbitrary
number of transactions uh batched down
to a single uh on chain transaction and
so the theoretical throughput of that uh
is in the you know the millions of
transactions a second and so when you
add that to
say side chains like liquid which has a
similar kind of scaling mechanism right
where you peg in bitcoin and then you
can trade this uh token into federation
much like proof of stake not not quite
the same but basically you can have this
much more rapid interaction between
these tokens and they can peg out to
kind of secure themselves on the main
chain and then two we see things like
say cash app comes along
and and that's a custodial uh scaling
service and so anyone that holds bitcoin
can send another can send bitcoin to
another cash app account for free
because that's just updating a database
inside of inside of cache app and so
whether you want trustless scaling like
lightning or trusted scaling like cache
app those are all being built on top of
the bitcoin base layer much like fedwire
let's go a little bit broader perhaps
into some social impacts or two sort of
interlinked questions i'll try to
yoke them together and you should uh
answer it as you see fit panelists from
julieta dexter do you think the
potential positive social impact of
crypto outweighs potentially negative
environmental
impact and there was a question which
was going to alex i'll go to alex first
which along the lines of do you dislike
bitcoin and crypto specifically would
you change your position
if it were used sustainably so i suppose
that's along the lines of you is there a
more philosophical underpinning to your
argument or is it really about uh data
points uh on environmental
damage alex why don't you take one or
both of those and then back to lynn
sure well you know um
do you just dislike bitcoin well i
actually don't dislike uh bitcoin at all
i think that bitcoin in essence does do
something unique which is that
it enables people to do decentralized
payments had to do peer-to-peer money
without the need for a government or
without a financial institution and you
could easily come up with a use case for
that because there are plenty of
countries where people are struggling
with corrupt authorities or institutions
and in that case it sounds ideal to have
something like peer-to-peer money now a
big problem right now is that bitcoin
isn't just struggling with you know the
energy consumption but also in terms of
uh scalability here on the bitcoin
blockchain itself the base layer you can
only put seven transactions per second
at most and the transaction fees of
doing a bitcoin transaction can go up to
more than 60 dollars which is a very big
problem because where i see bitcoin
potentially having value is in the type
of countries i just mentioned
but those are typically also low income
countries where people may have salaries
of 2500 a year or so they cannot afford
to use a system where the news using the
base layer cost 60 or more so
uh in in that sense
having the maximum social impact is kind
of made impossible by this other problem
that is scalability and that's also it's
a completely separate thing and we could
also have a discussion on that but
let me just summarize this as i do see a
potential positive value in bitcoin just
to say something nice
we go thank you thank you for saying
something something nice
um uh linda would you like to come back
on that i've got a
question that presses your case from
keith yeah we'll keep this around pretty
short
sure i would say that the the social
governance attributes of bitcoin as part
of the esg acronym are extremely
valuable for those reasons to basically
give those people access to
decentralized savings and payments
technology um and what we see for
example in el salvador right because
that's a it's an underbanked country
it's very impoverished a lot of
political turmoil in their past and the
reason they've taken towards bitcoin uh
prior to this announcement of it
becoming legal tender uh there's already
you know a large experiment going on
with bitcoin beach and again they were
not using the base layer they were using
lightning because they're using the
appropriate tool for the appropriate
situation kind of like how i don't use
fedora to buy coffee i don't use a 35
wire transfer to buy coffee uh you know
if i were gonna you know buy coffee i
use a visa card or cash whereas if i'm
going to do a small transaction with
bitcoin i'm going to use the appropriate
tool either a custody thing or or
something like lightning where it's it's
virtually free a fraction of one percent
of the of the cost of transaction
you know minimal
and you know those can cut down on
remittance fees right so we see a lot of
interest among developing countries that
are that are reliant on remittances
whether it's el salvador whether it's a
number of other countries um so i would
say again you have to use the
appropriate tool for the for the purpose
um and
you know it's basically i think it's
very powerful for emerging markets and
and developing countries around the
world
uh the challenge i wanted to give you
from keith uh says which i think is is
aimed at yulin if the examples you gave
are true
then using fossil fuel then they are
using fossil fuel energy not renewable
stranded natural gas can just be blocked
off it doesn't need to be put into the
atmosphere better
not to use it rather than to burn it um
um sorry keith it's just i i have to
gloss over some of the longer questions
they would much rather have fossil fuel
day and night and that's bad for the
economy
now they clarify the reason they need
that that stranded gas so they're
they're getting the hydrocarbons mainly
the petroleum uh that there is demand
for right so they're getting they're
they're mining oil uh they're getting
that out of the ground and that comes
with a small amount of natural gas now
it's a big amount of natural gas they
can build a pipeline because obviously
natural gas is useful they can build a
pipeline they can do all that
infrastructure and they can get that
natural gas with the with the oil back
to refining facilities the problem is
that a lot of these have a very small
natural gas amount of natural gas with
them and it's not economic for them to
do anything with it now they still have
to leave the well open because they're
getting the oil out for other purposes
totally unrelated to bitcoin and so they
take that natural gas and they say well
you know we got to burn it and and it's
a shame because again university
cambridge shows that that's the volume
of that around the world is eight times
the size of the amount of energy the
bitcoin network uses uh and so basically
we can see that we can come in uh we can
use that to mine bitcoin and actually
that can reduce methane being leaked out
because flaring that natural gas burning
it is not 100 efficient some of it gets
it out is methane which is even more
potent greenhouse gas whereas if you use
it in uh you know uh to turn it into
electricity and mine bitcoin it actually
you know reduces how much methane that's
why for example uh you know squares you
know bitcoin clean energy initiative has
has you know emphasized stranded natural
gas jack dorsey's talked about that a
number of times because it does help
reduce methane and it's not it's not gas
that could otherwise just be left there
because it's being pulled out with the
oil that's going to other purposes
thank you question from lcs in nyc
that's very mysterious proof of stake
proof of work it seems like currently
both platforms bitcoin and ethereum have
whale ownership even if proof of work
causes more equality it seems like
semantics at this point the idea that
crypto would make future financial
decisions more equal for the ordinary
person seems like a pipe dream uh alex
is lcs in nyc
uh a position you'd also agree with yes
well you know
i think in in in
just
really quickly respond to the previews
because i think what keith also tried to
say was that nowadays we have
technologies like vapor recovery units
that can actually help mitigating the
flare gas issue at oil extraction size
so why would we prefer to still burn it
rather than
use those perhaps cleaner solutions but
anyway you can comment on that if i'm
correct um let's see the other question
you forwarded to me and i think it just
got put to the
dismissed side
yeah
you know
will future financial systems be more
equal for the common person
i don't think it really matters whether
you have bitcoin or ethereum
because in either system most of the
wealth is
ultimately controlled by a limited
amount of people
it really doesn't matter whether uh you
go to bitcoin or ethereum so short
answer there then do you want to come
back on that and then we'll yeah i would
say
last couple of questions before we go to
closing remarks sure yeah it's a good
question i would say it's a lot more
impactful for ethereum because again
proof of stake means that the people who
that hold most of the coins get the have
control over the decisions kind of like
if you run a company and you own sixty
percent of the shares you basically run
that company um whereas with bitcoin it
doesn't matter if you're micro sailor or
the winklevoss twins would have you know
over a billion in bitcoin versus a small
user because the amount of coins you
hold does not affect your ability to
influence the network we actually saw
this play out it's not even theoretical
back in the 2017 block size wars we had
a large number of exchanges uh that the
large uh bitcoin miner that was
previously mentioned that owned a large
portion of the of the mining uh
infrastructure um a number of uh large
exchanges a number of big developers uh
former developers they were in favor of
expanding
bitcoin's block size which would have
made it harder to run a full node uh
harder for a smaller user to be able to
verify bitcoin um and it would have
increased the transaction throughput
which would have benefited the exchanges
would have benefited some of those other
players and that and they had at the at
the time 80 percent of the hash rate uh
bitcoin mining hash rate on their side
and they still failed to get that
through because of the distributed node
network and so that upgrade was never
done instead they went with a hard fork
that ultimately pretty much failed in
terms of market capitalization and usage
compared to bitcoin uh with bitcoin cash
and other derivatives they've had like
you know five or six of the
hard forks that tried that and so it's
actually shown through practice and in
theory that it's resilient to those
concentration efforts because again it's
not reliant on proofs of stake
and we look at you know
bitcoin concentration again a lot of the
large addresses uh that you see holding
most of the tokens those are actually
exchanges and other custodial addresses
that hold tokens for millions of people
and basically if you have proof of stake
those custodians could then vote on
their behalf kind of like how vanguard
and blackrock can vote on behalf of the
large pools of index funds they have an
influence policy uh whereas in a
proof-of-work system again it doesn't
really matter how many tokens you hold
in terms of your ability to influence
monetary policy or other policies on the
network
um hal ive who's asked a couple of good
questions how long at this point going
to cut cut to the the chase i want
because it's a good information point
which i think it's good to bring out
before we start to go to closing
statements and see what our audience
makes of of the debate what's the most
used energy source for mining excluding
coal any numbers on that do you two even
agree on uh that question what's the
most used energy source for mining
beyond coal alex
well i guess we won't agree but
[Music]
we booked you then isn't it
yeah
so what what what what was the most used
energy source of what will be the most
used energy what is uh he's gone for the
present tense that has helped so
yeah i i think yeah did good give any a
sort of situation as you understand it
and then
the thing is that this this network is
currently in a bit of a transition
because china recently banned bitcoin
mining so before china banned bitcoin
mining we had them using coal based
power during the winter time and then
during the summer time they were using
hydroelectric power so those
automatically became the biggest sources
of energy in the network because that's
where the majority of the network was
now
that has changed china kicked these
miners out and now they're relocating
elsewhere uh particularly notable
alberta canada where they are probably
going to house
maybe up to a third of the network and
that's all going to be powered by
natural gas
so
you know even if natural gas isn't the
primary source of energy at the moment
pretty soon it will be
right lynne just uh
answer to to that from your point of
view most energy so use source sorry for
mining excluded coal
yeah so we're seeing a mix it is true
that in china it fluctuated depending on
dry season wet season between hydro and
coal and so now that we've had this
excess out of china you know there's
different very you know so some sources
show about 40 percent of its renewable
other sources show up to about 70
renewables if you look at the bitcoin
mining council data
and so there's a varied number of
research of sources um i would say the
natural gas probably is going to be a
large portion but again a lot of that's
going to be stranded natural gas
uh rather than natural gas that's that's
produced specifically for bitcoin all
this you know around the margin some of
it is we can always pick out anecdotal
examples of you know a plant that was
going to go offline and instead is
brought back on because again bitcoin's
buyer of last resort and it says okay
there's a super cheap thing we can use
that um but we also see again i mean if
if quebec opened up you know we see a
lot of bitcoin mining in quebec using a
lot of their hydroelectric resources um
if they were to open up you know the
bitcoin miners would happily go there
uh we also see uh nuclear being
increasingly used for sources because
that's an always-on you know carbon free
source um and you know basically any
amount that's produced that's not
consumed within a certain number of
amount of distance uh would be wasted uh
and so you know bitcoin miners can go
and co-locate with them i know miners
that are doing that as we speak
and so i think we're going to see a
pretty distributed uh uh type rather
than any any one kind of dominant factor
i've got a challenge to you as we come
towards the close and we're going to
vote in just about four minutes so
please stay with us um but i've got a
cheeky uh
question here really a comment from alan
mayer but i think it will set you up
nicely for a very sharp uh no more than
two minutes maximum please closing we're
going to go to lynn first but alan says
this debate is unintelligible to me as a
layman i'm no wiser than i was at the
start well it is
inevitably you know a slightly complex
area with a lot of specialized language
and jargon but it does remind us that we
started with a pretty simple crypto
versus the environment question so i
could uh perhaps ask you both to try to
ask alan's point there and just keep it
as broad in conversation as you can and
sorry lyn i said i was going to go too
fast as as alex started us off tonight
crypto versus the environment sure so to
summarize it i would say that one
bitcoin brings a large number of
benefits to people
specifically the ability to use
permissionless payments to have a
savings technology that's separated from
an inflationary currency which in many
countries is very severe
and with additional layers that becomes
increasingly efficient is already doing
so in many of those emerging markets we
keep seeing more and more of those
places incorporate lightning uh into
their payments network and so it does
bring up a host of benefits then it does
use energy just like many other
industries it's comparable to the zinc
industry it's currently less than the
cruise industry uh you know it's it's
basically you know we can use headlines
like it uses as much electricity as
sweden but it sounds a lot less
sensational when you say it uses as much
electricity as zinc or less than the
cruise industry right so you can do
country comparisons you can do uh you
know industry comparisons but you know
there's
order magnitude more bitcoin users than
swedish citizens so it's not surprising
that the the network uses a lot of like
uh more energy
um and that it's important to keep in
mind that it's mostly non-rival energy
uh is you know so it kind of flows too
wherever there's sources of production
uh that are not being used uh for one
reason or another could be stranded gas
could be could be hydro that's not used
could be you know periods periods during
the week where nuclear and solar energy
are just not being heavily used um and
so it's getting increasingly efficient
basically bitcoin monitors go to
wherever there is uh the cheapest source
electricity and those cheap source
electricity tend to be places where
there's a supply demand mismatch between
the electricity so it kind of fills in
the gaps great uh flip straight over to
alex please and um
good idea no we better hear alex because
we can't hold till we've heard alex okay
very quick closing statement i like
alan's
challenge i think it's a very complex
issue and you know the thing is we are
dealing with digital money that is in
essence not that different from digital
dollars except there is no government or
other authority in control of your money
and in order you know to make this
system run we need the world's largest
random number generator that's consuming
more electricity than a country like
argentina
and obviously having a whole lot of
emissions along with that
to produce all that
energy
now
the system itself might have some value
for people around the world but in all
honesty bitcoin isn't really delivering
that at the moment because it is
extremely limited in terms of
scalability you know the dollar
can be used by anyone but bitcoin can
handle seven transactions per second on
the base layer is not a lot it's
extremely expensive it's slow
it's just not really capable of
delivering a whole lot of value other
than speculation but in the meanwhile we
do need that massive random
random number generator running in the
background that just grows as the value
of bitcoin grows in size it's not
related to any actual security need of
the network it just goes up as the
bitcoin price goes up and that's the
unfortunate situation we're in and we
can hopefully fix that by changing the
software so at least bitcoin can serve
its niche function without having this
environmental impact but in order to do
that we first need to get agreement
within this community on the best
possible change to make to this software
thank you very much alex and you
addressed a question from keith about uh
argentina bitcoin using more electricity
than argentina along the way so we've
got another question in there without
even having heard it right let's move to
the vote is crypto a threat to the
environment you know the drill yes no
undecided
please vote and now
but
and while um
they're doing that and the crypto names
in the background are uh counting up in
the old way i'd like to remind you this
is the second in the intelligence crypto
series if you enjoyed us do join the
third crypto can bank the unbanked is
the proposition peter mccormack and yaya
fanuc on september 9th of course if you
register on the intelligence squad
website you can catch the first fiery
debate uh bitcoin versus gold with
anthony scaramucci and peter schiff
right i'm just going to wait for the new
results to come in and i think they are
about to emerge is crypto a threat to
the environment reminding ourselves the
pre-vote was 40 yes 20 percent 26
percent no 34 undecided the final vote
is 32 yes 43 no and 25
undecided so
um there was a pretty sharp move there
in the direction of the nose and they
came i think yeah well they came from
both the original yeses and the
undecideds
so um yeah people were changing their
minds as they went along thank you very
much for your questions i got through as
many as i i could they were excellent
questions i'm sorry if i i didn't get to
all of them but of course you can
continue that debate on twitter but i
would most of all like to thank our
speakers to lynn alden and alex therese
fascinating debate and the audience of
course for for coming along tonight and
pushing us all along with your questions
and partners equinex for staging the
debate and supporting the series uh
thanks for joining us hope you've
enjoyed it learnt something from it and
that we managed at least to demystify
some of the jargon along the way thanks
very much